In Indonesia, the death toll has climbed to 28...
...following a bus crash that also left 13 people injured on Sumatra island.
In Hong Kong, protesters clashed with police in the busy tourist area of Tsim Sha Tsui,...
...in several shopping malls, as months-long pro-democracy protests continued.
Areas of Australia that have experienced wildfires saw relief,...
...but oppressive conditions are expected to return in the coming days.
In Chile, a forest fire on Christmas Eve has destroyed dozens of homes in Valparaiso,...
...about 120 kilometers west of Santiago.
Thousands of Christian pilgrims flocked to the West Bank town of Bethlehem,...
...celebrating Christmas in what Christians believe is the traditional birthplace of Jesus.